je vous parle beaucoup de smartphones de
chez eux au milieu assez peu d'astuce je
sais que ça pourrait être pas mal de
venir vous donner quelques bonnes
astuces sur un smartphone de chevigny or
quel que soit votre smartphone de shiomi
dès lors vous êtes sur me wade ou non ça
c'est plutôt bien aujourd'hui on va
garder pas moins de 10 astuces pour bien
utiliser votre smartphone shiomi j'en ai
un ici ça c'est un chien omis on se tait
pro si vous en avez un autre pouvez
également l'utiliser et vous allez voir
vous allez apprendre des jeux
les deux premières astuces vous
serviront vraiment pour venir les
utiliser pour devenir les maîtres vous
les connaissez probablement vous les
avez d'ailleurs déjà probablement fait
la toute première ça va être devenir
active et son tiroir d'application et
ben ouais ça c'est vachement important
vous venez ici dans vos paramètres et
vous allez ici dans l'écran d'accueil
alors par défaut vous avez un écran
d'accueil classique ne vous avait pas de
tiroirs d'applications toutes vos
applications sont rangés les lieux à la
suite des autres que c'est pas
extraordinaire on est 100 droid il faut
profiter justement du tiroir
d'applications dont convient active est
ici ce qui fait que lorsque vous arrivez
là vous avez votre tiroir d'application
avec vos apps ces pratiques par amandine
astuces mais faut vraiment bien le ter
le deuxième point c'est pareil vous
retournez dans vos paramètres vous
retournez sud en écran d'accueil vous
allez dans système de navigation et au
lieu de naviguer avec des boutons ou
sectionné geste alors on s'en fiche de
les apprendre mais c'est beaucoup mieux
plus simple c'est passé bouton en bas
voilà ça c'est vraiment les deux
prérequis je voulais mais en deux
astuces que ce sont vraiment deux
astuces à connaître mais je vous
conseille vraiment de venir faire ça ça
va venir simplifier l'utilisation de
votre smartphone ça c'est un très grand
classique sur android si vous le saviez
pas on commence par la base et il faut
le faire alors maintenant on va aller un
peu plus loin la troisième optimisation
et bien les lier à ce que vous avez ici
on va regarder c'est ce qu'on va appeler
la sécurité vous avez cette application
sécurité sur vos smartphones de chez
tommy et c'est vachement cool regardez
ça vous ouvre tout une grande ap vous
allez avoir beaucoup de choses sur la
sécurité on allait prévenir optimiser
votre smartphone facilement vous avez un
nettoyeur gardien regarder nettoyer
après venir nettoyer l'espace à vous
montrer ce qu'ils déploient à venir
supprimés donc la voyez fichiers en cash
j'ai 212 que je peux venir supprimer
fichiers obsolètes gens n'aient pas à
supprimer des paquets j'en ai pas
quelques petits résidus un peu de
mémoire donc la cij fait nettoyés déjà
je gagne 500 ans 30 520 est mort ça déjà
c'est quand même pas mal et ça me permet
gagner un petit peu de place donc ça
c'est vachement cool ok ça c'est le
premier point ensuite pour nettoyer pas
mal de choses whatsapp facebook nous
trions profondeur plus vraiment viré des
fichiers gagner de la place vous n'avez
plus beaucoup ça c'est vachement bien et
puis après vous avez aussi d'analystes
de sécurité je conseille de venir faire
également c'est vachement important on
regarde la confidentialité on regarde
s'il ya des virus hockey ici tout va
bien vous avez aussi la question de la
batterie qui est vachement importante
qui vous marque combien de temps il vous
reste alors là je suis sur un chiot me
on se tait proust recharge de 200% en 17
minutes mais si vous n'êtes pas
seulement un smartphone qui se charge
aussi rapidement et que vous voulez
économiser votre batterie eh bien
regardez pas choisir entre la chienlit
qui libre et je peux mettre en énergie
taxe gagne un petit peu leur performance
un plat là les performances je descends
je perds l'équilibré samira bien donc je
peux avoir également l'économiseur de
batterie ultra alors et hop là il ne
reste 46 eur bon je peux plus à grand
chose mais j'ai quand même 40 6 heures
alors bon je suis en thèmes sombres j'ai
plus grand chose regardez il me reste
que trois applications alors c'est pas
le but ici donc je viens de quitter mais
si vous n'avez plus beaucoup de batterie
que vous avez besoin de batterie pour
juste passer un coup de fil ou recevoir
un message vous passez dans ce mode là
et ça pourrait venir un petit peu vous
sauver la vie alors vous avez pas notre
chose ici qui sont super intéressante
vous pouvez augmenter la vitesse de
votre mémoire vous voulez vraiment tout
optimisé c'est une application qui sont
vachement intéressante qui vous permet
d'aller beaucoup plus loin au niveau de
l'utilisation de votre smartphone et il
ya un autre point qui est vachement cool
regardez vous venez en bas ces planqués
tout en bas tout le temps va tout s'en
va ici vous avez une application
confidentialité dans cette application
vous allez voir quelles sont les
applications qui vont venir utiliser
votre localisation avoir accès à vos
contacts à votre journal d'appels à
votre microphone donc ça c'est quand
même vachement important comme ça vous
voyez vraiment score dès la joie parfois
que pour le micro mais j'ai l'appareil
photo g les messages et le téléphone est
que google est toujours autorisé à
utiliser mon micro je veux bien mais
pourquoi ce google est toujours autorisé
10 m au micro je sais pas donc je vais
dessus et je peux le soir refusé ce soit
autorisée alors pour moi google n'a pas
toujours utiliser mon micro dont je veux
dire allez hop on refuse aux plats donc
effectivement toute la fonctionnalité ok
google on l'aura pas ici mais est ce que
j'en ai besoin tout de suite bon voilà
ça c'est à vous de voix on l'a sur le
micro on l'a également sur le journal
d'appels hockey dont j'ai google et le
téléphone la localisation j'ai une fois
de plus google qui est autorisé google
et beaucoup autorisé fait attention à ça
il semblait vraiment toutes les
autorisations vous donner c'est pour moi
un élément essentiel est hyper important
de votre vie on est quatrièmes astuces
qui est intéressant c'est la question
des fenêtre flottante alors quand vous
recevez une notification doit venir à
passer en fenêtre flottante ici vous
avez pas eu notification comme pouvait
le faire adhérer dans le multitâche on
va s'ouvrir youtube sera déjà une petite
vidéo de moitié sur youtube donc là vous
avez ça et hop regardez vous venez dans
votre multitâche vous avez fenêtre
flottante juste en haut et ensuite vous
choisissez ce que vous voulez mettre en
fenêtre flottante un petit facebook un
petit message un petit photo allez on va
se dire un petit twitter par exemple ici
et là j'ai deux buteurs qui s'ouvre une
fenêtre flottante alors c'est plutôt
sympa effectivement eu de botox que tu
as bien faire sa r&d peut venir la
déplacer par exemple lors d'une vidéo je
naviguais compas d'imagés salage que
lire aussi la réduire la mettre à la
taille à laquelle je veux garder par
exemple je la prends je la mets en eau
et la rai son côté donc là je veux bien
faire tout ce que j'ai envie de faire
que utiliser des emails je peux venir
naviguer sur internet regarder des
vidéos j'ai ma fenêtre tout en rassurant
les besoins oui et non ça dépend des usa
ça dépend de la fenêtre est ce qu'on va
en faire et lorsque je veux la rouvrir
en grand je viens au plat je clique
dessus et je l'ouvré en grand et tac
voilà je vous demande d'application donc
ça c'est assez rigolo pour venir activer
votre fenêtre flottante mais il suffit
de venir dans vos paramètres vous venez
ici dans fonctionnalités spéciales vous
avez la fenêtre flottante et là vous
avez un petit tuto qui vous explique
comment ça marche c'est très pratique
autre fonctionnalité que je trouve
vraiment cool vous pouvez venir modifier
une vidéo que vous regardez par exemple
sur youtube venir modifier les filtres
ou bien faire des captures d'écran peut
venir enregistrer la vidéo alors le but
ce n'est pas d'enregistrer les vidéos
vous râlez sur youtube parce que vous
n'avez pas les droits vous n'avez pas
l'autorisation mais des fois une petite
capture d'écran ça ces pratiques alors
je vous montre ça serait sympa aussi
vous venez ici dans vos paramètres vous
retournez dans les fonctionnalités
spéciales et vous allez dans boîte à
outils vidéo et là vous venez l'activer
la boîte à outils vidéo voyez elle est
juste là par défaut elle est activée
vous venez l'activé alors on peut
choisir également l'endroit auquel elle
sera elle sera à gauche par ici et en
plus gérer les applications qui vont
fonctionner avec ses boîtes à outils
vidéo moi je vous ai mis youtube une
vidéo instagram twitter chrome netflix
tik tok pu en avoir plein d'autres donc
ça c'est à vous de voir en fonction des
applications qui seront installés sur
votre téléphone alors regardez retourne
sur youtube j'ai ma vidéo qui est là et
qui est en train d'être tournée si vous
regardez juste en haut à droite vous
l'avez ici la regarde et hop vous
appuyez dessus et là vous avez votre
petite fenêtre enregistrement l'écran
capture d'écran grade et hop ça fait une
petite capture d'écran que vous allez
retrouver ici vous pouvez envoyer à
quelqu'un si vous voulez très facilement
bon ok donc ça c'est assez rigolo mais
on peut aller beaucoup plus loin
regardez vous pouvez par exemple
améliorer la vidéo donc passé ap la rade
et je clique j'améliore savament
augmenter la résolution bon on l'a déjà
je suis déjà en 4k on n'est déjà pas mal
regardez il ya donc très rigolo le style
là sur l'original weibring tu veux venir
à colorer un peu plus hdr nostalgie noir
et blanc je peux le passé en show bref
ça au sérieux c'est marrant parce que si
tu regarde une vidéo il j'aime pas la
colorimétrie ça c'est très très bizarre
eh ben je peux bien faire des choses joe
des fois un peu bizarre mais pourquoi
pas regarder la up robot c'est très vert
tout ça c'est à vous de voir et en
fonction de ce que vous aimez regarder
ou pas et puis ensuite pour venir
partager sur différents réseaux très
facilement et joue donc la sixième
astuces que se trouve vachement bien
alors regardez on retourne sur la même
vidéo c'est à peu près la même chose
mais comme c'est une autre astuce
voulait vraiment la partage avec vous
qu'est ce qui se passe quand vous
regardez une vidéo youtube mais regardez
c'est comme ça et quand vous essayez de
téléphone eh ben ça s'arrête et bien
justement il ya une astuce qui est
vachement cool on va remettre la vidéo
on reste toujours dans la boîte à outils
vidéo
appuyer la regarder vous devrez juste
ici sur le côté et vous avez lire le son
avec l'écran et vous appuyez dessus hop
là ça coûte vous pouvez écouter donc le
truc est vachement intéressant pourquoi
parce que si vous voulez écouter par
exemple une vidéo youtube en notre
podcast en ayant l'écran éteint là vous
pouvez faire et ça c'est vraiment génial
parce qu'on peut pas bien le faire
autrement lorsque vous regardez une
vidéo youtube donc on peut utiliser
n'importe quelle vidéo youtube et des
coûts top 4 je me sens super bien la 7e
astuces ses protégés des applications
qui sont confidentiels si par exemple
que le coeur récupère vos smartphones et
qu'il est déverrouillé eh bien ils ne
pourront pas accéder à certaines
applications parce qu'elles seront
verrouillées par un mot de passe ou par
schéma supplémentaires alors je me
comment ça se passe vous venez ici dans
vos paramètres vous allez dans
applications et vous avez donc
verrouillage d'applications juste en bas
alors moi je ne montre pas mais je fais
mon petit chama active et l'empreinte
digitale hockey en train de vérifier et
donc la regarder là je vous ai déjà dit
et messenger mais par exemple on peut se
dire quoi ben on peut se dire j'en sais
rien qu'est ce que je veux mes messages
par exemple perdu ne serait ce que mes
sms et mazout mais cette baisse ne
puisse pas y accéder si on n'a pas accès
à mon empreinte digitale ou avons schéma
ce qui fait que la voyez suis sur mon
smartphone je vais dans les messages hop
on me demande le schéma où l'empreinte
digitale et s'il ne l'est pas on ne peut
pas accéder on peut pas lire mes
messages c'est une sécurité
supplémentaire dépose mon doigt et
ensuite ça marche bon ok c'est parti on
voyait surtout qui est vachement cool
vous permet de venir protéger certaines
applications en plus sur lequel il y
aura besoin de sécurité supplémentaires
à les huitièmes astuce il reste encore
trois ans va se les faire la huitième
astuces et devenir tapoter sur votre
téléphone pour venir faire des actions
alors on ne connaît déjà sur certains
smartphones mais ici regardez ça existe
également alors je vous montez vous
venez ici vous avez dans vos paramètres
vous aller dans les paramètres
supplémentaires juste ici et dans vos
paramètres supplémentaires vous allez
dans raccourcis vers les gestes et de
raccourcis vers les gestes vous allez
d'en garder juste en bas ici appuyé en
arrière alors hop on a pu ici en arrière
alors j'ai déjà mois par la mettrez vous
pouvez appuyer deux fois pour une action
appuyée trois fois pour une action alors
moi j'ai mis appuyé deux fois lancer
l'appareil photo mais ça peut être
n'importe quoi ça peut être à effectuer
une capture d'écran centre de contrôle
panneaux de notification lancé
l'incident google l'appareil photo et
calculatrice le mode silencieux pour
obtenir des journaux liés aux problèmes
et ensuite regarder c'est pareil pour le
3 fois venez paramétrer l'action vous
voulez également donc tout ça vachement
cool vous preniez votre smartphone vous
tapotez le dos et vous arrivez dans ce
que vous voulez et il ya une autre
action qui est intéressante là juste en
dessous regardez c'est le capteur
d'empreintes digitales la double
pression or vous choisissez également
pouvez faire tout un tas d'actions
allumé la torche centre de contrôle à
notification lancé l'instant google
lancer l'appareil photo la calcul triste
le mode silencieux obtenir les journaux
liés aux problèmes ou carrément rien
d'un mois j'ai mis allumé la torche qui
fait que celui-là mon smartphone est
verrouillé j'appuie la fois s'allume la
torche avec la touche c'est pratique et
surtout tout bête mais c'est pratique
allez nous reste deux astuces regarde à
une astuce de sécurité que je trouve
aussi super importante vous venez ici
dans tac tac tac tac mot de passe et
sécurité vous allez en bas dans
autorisation et révocation qui se situe
juste ici pour venir évoquer des
autorisations liées à vos applications
ces crises y regarder autorisations
accordées votre autorisation sera
révoqué après avoir basculé les boutons
des applications individuelles dont
clash venir évoquer les mises à jour la
sécurité bref j'en ai pas mal à vous de
voir si un sens à le faire ou pas signer
des autorisations vous voulez révoqué
c'est toujours une notion de sécurité
alors attention c'est pas n'importe quoi
il faut vraiment savoir ce qu'on vient
faire ici est ce qu'on le désactiver
pour pas voir de problème si vous voulez
révoquer des autorisations vous dit
peut-être jamais de l'autorisation pour
ses applications là on l'a dit koch et
elle n'aura plus d'autorisation à
l'élève 10e astuces et trouve trop cool
et je voulais vraiment venir la partager
avec vous c'est de pouvoir mixer
directement le 2 dans votre smartphone
sur différentes sources alors c'était un
peu fouillis comme ça nous allait voir
vous venez une fois de plus dans vos
paramètres vous venez dans son et
vibrations et vous allez dans
l'assistance ont juste ici pour une
active et de casa justel son multimédia
dont plusieurs applications et plusieurs
sources audio ce qui fait que par
exemple peut mettre une vidéo sur
youtube il peut mettre de la musique sur
spotify qui peut voir les deux en même
temps et je vais me régaler leçon de
l'un et l'autre a perdu et bien je vous
demande par exemple je veux mettre de la
musique à l'âge mais sur chrome et je me
mets sur épidémique sans histoire de pas
voir de problème de droits d'auteur gema
vidéo youtube sur laquelle je parle donc
la voyez j'entends préfet mal c'était
hyper fort regardez j'ai mon volume
j'appuie sur le bouton là et là j'ai mes
différentes sources en europe
je vais me laisser ma musique là voilà
et lazreg l'a fait écouter un peu de
musique spectateurs youtube derrière
pour toutes à tout ce qui va être que de
la voix ce que si elles allaient ils
font de la musique sera pas bon vous
voyez je touche le bouton volume si
c'est ça qui apparaît j'appuie et là
j'ai mes différentes sources assez le
masters c'est global et après voilà que
choisir montella dc l'autre super comme
je ne on va être un peu de musique
derrière voilà alors si j'écoute un taux
de 4 il ya comme la voix et le jeu un
peu de musique derrière parce que faire
la même chose dont je trouve ça
extrêmement malin est vachement cool
voilà pour ces 10 astuces sur un chien
oui j'espère que vous aurez appris peu à
peu et ça vous aura intéressé d'ailleurs
marqué le mois en commentaire et si vous
avez vous aussi des astuces sur un
smartphone de chérubin premier marqué
juste en bas en commentaire et dites moi
ça vous intéresse que je vous fasse
d'autres astuces pratiques pour savoir
bien utiliser son smartphone de shiomi
vous marquez bien évidemment tout ça en
bas en commentaire elle retrouve très
vite pour continuer à parler tech
continue à parler de lui parce que
croyait ben oui sur shiomi il ya plein
d'actus qui arrive et ça c'est vachement
intéressant allez des bisous d'amour
pour les soins de vous il ya très
distincts